to say it's dry
in the american west is a major
understatement the u.s drought
monitor reported this week the most
intense drought in the region in modern
history the consequences are significant
for the economy of the west and the rest
of the country which depends on
resources
that come from there cbs news climate
specialist jeff berdelli is back with us
jeff jeff when you compare last year's
drought
to this year's drought considering that
last year was the worst
fire season in modern history it paints
a picture of just how dangerous the
situation is right now
i traveled to california where
scientists are using clues from ancient
trees
to put the current drought into
perspective and help us
learn from past droughts and help
mitigate the current situation
decoding the past secrets of our western
climate
starts in california's iconic forest
these trees will certainly provide us
with that nice elegant record of the
past
dr john abbotseglu studies the evidence
hidden
in the rings of these ancient trees we
can use this sort of
long-term record here from these tree
rings where we go from wet periods to
dry periods to wet periods and that
allows us really to go back prior to
when we were measuring
a climate with thermometers and rain
gauges
modern measurements are no match for the
longevity of the tree record
but once you have these trees you can go
back thousands of years it's really sort
of an art
basically sort of you know pasting these
tree rings together to get a record that
goes back
upwards of a thousand years the case he
and his colleagues cracked and then
published in a landmark paper in the
journal science
revealed astounding findings the west
is now in the midst of the worst drought
since at least medieval times
this is one of the worst if not the
worst sort of 22-year period of lean
years we've seen
going back through 1200 years of tree
ring records across the southwest
a mega drought on steroids fueled by
warming and drying from human-caused
climate change
with shocking symptoms showing up
throughout the west
the snowpack has melted two months early
and streams are at a trickle
just as summer begins california's 154
reservoirs
are only at 50 percent capacity like
this one
just to the west of yosemite in fact
right now if this was full
i'd be under 80 feet of water and
western wildfire season
is already underway weeks ahead of time
a sign that things may be picking up
where they left off last fall
2020's catastrophic castle fire tore
through
tens of thousands of ancient sequoia
trees incinerating in a day
what had been growing here for thousands
of years the devastating loss was
uncovered by another
important tree study this one by christy
brigham
of the national park service the oldest
giant sequoia we think is about
3 200 to 3 500 years can you imagine how
many humans have come and gone
during that time and how many droughts
how many wildfires
christie is the chief of resource
management and science for sequoia
and kings canyon national parks so your
study found that more than 10
percent of all the sequoias in the world
died in this particular fire
yeah and not just all the sequoias but
the big ones the ones that really tug at
our heartstrings that make us feel a
spiritual connection
to eternity because they've lived so
long this is not about
climate change in the future or
somewhere else this is climate change
here in our backyard and
uh affecting some of the greatest
heritage
that this country has clay jordan is the
superintendent of the parks
how do you manage this iconic forest so
we lost 10 percent
of the sequoias but that they're still
90 percent
and that we haven't lost we know we need
to
introduce more fire on the landscape but
we need to do so with care
so you're fighting fire with fire yes
absolutely
but even with controlled burns to cut
away the amount of fuels around the
trees
is it really any match for the
amplifying drum beat of climate change
john a botsuglu is looking for those
answers in the tree rings
is it possible we could emerge sometime
soon from this drought
it is possible we need a series of
really wet years
that said right the odds are stacked
against us because
the warming atmosphere that we've seen
and that tax on our water supply is
likely not going away it's likely only
going to intensify
you found that mega droughts are a lot
longer than 20 years we've only been in
this drought 20 years so is it possible
this could last a lot longer
the drought that we're seeing this year
is still sort of a baby mega drought
it's not that old
right and it could grow it could we
could be talking in 10 years about a
30-year mega drought or in 20 years
about a 40-year mega drought
but right now park managers have more
immediate concerns
keeping today's tinderbox conditions
from sparking instantaneous devastation
in the forest they care for
so this is the worst now drought in 1200
years if you look at the 22 year period
when we started back in 2000
now you asked how they know looking at
these tree rings right
so the thinner the tree ring the more of
a drought
that was happening during that
particular time the thicker the more
rain that was available for these tree
rings to grow
so it's pretty easy to piece it together
and this is now the worst when you
combine
last year and this year 22-year period
drought we have ever seen in the last
1200 years
the loss of those trees that history
that majesty it just
breaks my heart great word for it thank
you jeff you're welcome